Now with the Stefinator, welcome to the Stefinator, maximum pumps, maximum pumps.
And now, you see it's power, now it's maximum.
Steff makes it look easy.
And you can see now also, the level goes down.
Yep. You can always follow the level here, yeah?
Yeah, you always see the level.
And now I show you what happens when there is a problem.
Camera is on.
We have here different functions.
Here we have light.
So these lights go on by night when we work by night.
And we have a problem.
Emergency switch.
Now the engine is completely off.
So it shows you also the temperature.
You see, now it's on, now the engine is off.
When this bulb is on in work, then the oil temperature is too high.
Was it on? No.
That was what we all need to show you.
Important is, now you can do nothing.
The machine never starts again.
First you must push back the button.
Yep, because that's a trip switch basically.
Yes. And now I can go in the front and start it again.
The whole process.
Battery not needed because the battery is on?
No, no, everything is on.
You can see it now here.
Come up.
You see now everything is like we start.
Now the only thing is push the clutch because the pump is connected on.
Now we can start and directly it starts working again.
Yep.
And now the pump is working again.
That was the security part.
Ok, so we go back to the pump and the hose and the fire gun.
So it is also, what?
A little bit the throttle.
Ok, we must put the throttle a little bit.
Tell me.
And that is the normal way to fight the fire with two persons.
So this is one professional way, yeah?
Yeah, one in front with the gun and another one who secure him with the hose.
Yeah.
So not with black.
Normally you have fire protection clothes.
Ok.
That is also a skill because when you have these clothes it is really warm and in a weather like this you start sweating a lot.
Yep.
So it is very important always to have cold water inside.
And the next thing is for us it is very important to use this truck every week because when we have the water longer time inside the tank it starts rusting the tank and also the water gets green.
So it is important to use the machine.
If not the ventiles, the pumps, wheels and everything start clogging about the green plants inside the water.
So you should not just leave water there for weeks.
So normally now it was I think one month and you can see it here on the filling level.
It was completely green.
You can see it there a little bit.
I dismantled it today and cleaned it.
And now you can see it.
When it starts getting green then it is really important to empty it.
Let's fill it new.
Ok.
That is it. Thanks.
So now the fire is off.
We are safe.
Everything is good.
No burning houses, no cars, no trees.
Everything is fine.
So now we go and put back the throttle on the lowest level.
So now it is here it stops.
Here there is a mark with the plus and the minus.
So now put the clutch and the black one.
Now the pump is off.
So now we can stop the engine.
Then we push the black button.
Everything is off.
And now we go out and clean the space.
Put the hose back inside.
We have begun everything.
Roll it again.
So they make everything safe and then we left the moment.
Ok?
To roll the hose, not with the adapter.
You must push the wheel here inside.
Then we have here the roll.
Now I start here.
Now someone must go on the wheel.
Safe.
And turn it no other direction.
Now we are rolling the hose.
And this time the hose also emptied.
So all the water inside goes out.
As you roll it, yeah?
Yeah. When you put it on the roll.
So it is important to empty the hoses after work.
Because if not, they glue together.
So then make it like this.
Then here is the locking point.
Now it can't move.
How do you lock it? Can you shut?
Out. That's open.
There is a hole.
Close.
And when it is open, you make it like this and it stays open.
Yes.
If not, when you make it like this.
You can lock it directly.
It is in the hole.
So basically this hole here.
Okay.
Do it nice.
Why change the tip?
Because when these parts are attached.
So you took the thing from here, right?
You took it from here and you put it inside.
This is an adapter to put the hose.
But we must dismantle everything.
Because Jeremy one time loses one of these adapters.
Because he was installed.
And from shaking by driving, it loses and then it falls down.
Okay. Then we can drive.
Again.
To the next fire.
Okay. All in.
Anything you have to share about these cabinets?
Yeah. They are not good locking.
But I will work on this.
It is important to have on the driver's side in the first part.
We have all the special tools.
The adapters, the guns.
This is a part for sucking water from a river or from a well.
That we train later.
Just for the cinematics.
Super Mike driving to the next fire.
What is the most exciting thing about this whole experience Mike?
I don't know really.
Oh, we have here a lot of dead trees.
So what is happening here Mike?
Here is a big fire.
All the weed is burning.
Step one. Cabinets.
Yes. Open.
Find the pieces.
Small adapter. Fire gun.
So bring the fire gun to Joe.
Fire gun is a hand to drone.
We are going to put a fire gun on the hose.
Boom. One person fire gun.
Mike is setting the adapters.
Outlets.
Make sure it is fully loaded.
All the side. Ready?
That was quick.
It is on.
Struggle is on now.
Ok, so then.
Here is a license for that.
He drives the Caterpillar inside fire.
Because he was a soldier in Portugal.
And all the soldiers have the option to train this.
But they must do it every year.
Yes.
That is why I ask him to stay with us.
I am not sure.
I don't know.
I ask him to stay with us.
He knows a little bit about that.
Be careful.
Now it is full power.
Fire extinguisher.
Slowly. Stop.
Put out the wheel.
So now when everything is back.
Engine off.
So again engine off is on the left button.
Yes, under the clutch.
Under the clutch. Ok.
Brake is on. Everything off.
And now we can start cleaning the machine.
Ok.